by now you know that Logan is a creative
and critical success because of the
movies relentless pace it's easy to miss
out on the significance of anyone who
isn't Wolverine Professor X or Laura
despites the brief appearances of
supporting characters they all come with
a complex comics history here's a guide
to the characters from Logan with more
meaning than you realize and of course
if you haven't seen Logan yet avert your
eyes
Donald pious in Logan
Donald Pierce's the primary antagonist
while there are villains who are more
powerful and diabolical it's the robot
handed Pierce and his band of Reavers
who relentlessly hunt
x-23 and Logan wherever they go in
Marvel's comic universe there's much
more to Pierce when we first meet him in
uncanny x-men number 132 he's an
exceptionally funky cyborg member of the
Hellfire Club who are nothing but bad
news for the x-men he was eventually
kicked out of the Hellfire Club since he
basically joins to kill the club's
mutant leaders and an uncanny x-men
number 251 he reappears with the Reavers
after sweeping all of them up with
cybernetic enhancements and literally
crucifying Wolverine on a giant X
because Pierce is nothing if not subtle
in his comics incarnation everything
about Pierce's cybernetic except his
head and he can even survive even if
everything else has been destroyed all
in all this is much more impressive that
is comparatively simple robohand in the
movie the Reavers those nameless
soldiers with robot parts but followed
Donald Pierce to Wolverine and x-23
repeatedly cut into ribbons are the
Reavers as far as Logan goes those guys
were pretty weak stuff because like
seriously they were beaten up by a
little girl and that guy literally have
a gun for an arm in the comics however
the Reavers each have distinctive
abilities and the reasons to hate
Wolverine they also have totally badass
late 80s names like skullbuster bone
breaker Lady Deathstrike and pretty boy
he has combines these cyborgs with a few
hellfire mercenaries who's been torn
apart by Wolverine and repaired with
robot parts and the Reavers are born
before meeting Pierce some of them use
the teleporting mutant gateway to commit
robberies all over the world
they've also tangled with everyone's
favorite heroic murderer in punisher
number 33 but like their destructible
detachable body parts the Reavers always
come back new and improved they're
basically an 80s cyberpunk vision
brought to life which probably explains
why their look was toned down for Logan
we had more than enough of that in Mad
Max
Caliburn this guy continues to pop up in
unexpected places we last saw him in
x-men apocalypse where he
just mystique money to find mutants and
help ferry them to safety a very
different version pops up again in Logan
as someone who once used his mutants
tracking abilities to help Pierce and
others hunt mutants but now serves up an
assistance to Charles Xavier and Logan
while he's given a moving arc in Logan
caliban's comic incarnation have a
richer backstory when we first see
Caliban in uncanny x-men number 148 he's
in the middle of a creepy misadventure
where he uses his super strength as a
bunch of Spider Woman through a window
an abducted teenage Kitty Pryde mostly
because he just wants a pal later things
get more intense an uncanny x-men number
179 when Caliban is tired of being
friend-zoned and abducts kitty and the
slaps are in some kind of sewer wedding
dress so he can marry her which is not
as romantic as it sounds he eventually
lets her go when he realizes a really
poor dating strategy later he ends up
living with x-factor by issue number 24
of their ongoing series Caliban
frustrated that his tracking power
doesn't give him real power ask
apocalypse for a boost he ends up
becoming apocalypses horseman of death
with increased strength and intelligence
thanks to genetic alterations by
apocalypse himself he eventually
divorces apocalypse and joins x-force
but only until apocalypse brings him
back into the fold as the horseman of
pestilence eventually Caliban returns
back to its barely articulate self
before getting killed in new x-men
number 45 and then because it's comics
he gets resurrected and killed again
it's a pretty complex arc of power and
redemption that's Logan only kind of
touches on Rickster perhaps one of the
most surprising faces we see in Logan is
Rick sir the de facto leader of a group
of fellow young mutants who have also
escaped experimentation just like his
comic council path he has psychic powers
and shows natural leadership abilities
but that's all we get to see during his
brief time on screen
Richter first appeared in x-factor
number 17 where he's tracked down by
none other than Caliburn after being
rescued from a group of using his powers
he's welcomed into x-factor he later
joins the new mutants by issue number 77
first leaves to join Weapon prime in
x-force number 11
a group whose sole purpose is hunting
down cable who Richter believes killed
his father a few issues later he
realizes the error of his ways and joins
x-force which is led by cable the dude
is pretty indecisive as a member of just
about every x-men team ever
rictus didn't even give up fighting evil
when he lost his powers during the house
of M event he joined x-factor
investigations under the leadership of
Jamie madrix
the multiple man who if you think about
it it's probably the worst person to
have as your boss x24 one of the more
interesting films throwbacks in Logan is
the appearance of x24 an imperfect clone
of Logan that mostly exists so we can
watch Wolverine in a mirror match
against himself
well x24 doesn't really exist in the
comics there are a few Marvel characters
that he maybe a riff on spiritually x24
seems pretty similar to Albert a
robotics duplicate of Wolverine that was
built by Donald Pierce and Wolverine
number 37 in order to kill his mutant
nemesis Albert eventually gets over his
programming and becomes an ally of
Wolverine however the movie makes it
clear that x24 is a clone rather than a
robotics duplicate which seems to
reference more recent comics essentially
around x-23 early Adventures of the
all-new Wolverine at the start of her
solo series she encounters a few clone
versions of herself who are seeking
vengeance on their creators they all
have different personalities which seems
to be a major step above the mindless
killing machine briefly portrayed in
Logan dr. reisen's Gabriella Logan
doesn't show as much of dr. rice the man
behind the program that's cloning and
training young mutants peers even
credits the guy for causing the
extinction of mutants which is a pretty
big deal his quick death means that we
don't get to see the full depth of his
relationship with the young mutants but
just like the film the dr. rice of the
comics is significant to x-23 even if
he's only in a few issues in Marvel
Comics we first glimpse doctors on the
right of the youngest scientists in x-23
number one carrying on is farmers legacy
with the Weapon X program bad science
goes down when dr. Sara Kinney is
brought into the project and the only
way to save her work is to have an
embryonic x-23 clone popped into her
womb which she brings to term which is a
whole lot more intense than
Gabriella's rollin Logan so that's when
dr. rice takes over torturing the young
Laura to bring out her mutant abilities
including extracting her claws by
poisoning her with radiation and
building in a trigger scent that drives
her into a berserker rage whenever she
smells it
rice uses a brainwash to Laura as a
mercenary to slaughter dozens of people
including just about everyone in a
fellow scientist family Laura ends up
killing dr. rice and destroying the
Weapon X facility but rice gets his
final revenge he manages to slip the
trigger sentient doctor Kenny's hair so
Laura ends up murdering the only person
who ever loved her as she lays dying we
see an envelope full of information
about where X 23 should go to visit
Logan and Professor X sound familiar
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know your love to
[Music]